[Musique]
les youtubeurs McFly et Carlito ont
comme prévu été invités par le chef de
l'État pour se livrer à un joyeux
concours d'anecdotes 36 minutes de
programme qui doivent servir à Emmanuel
Macron à se rapprocher des jeunes mais
la balance bénéfice risque devrait être
observée de près estime Pierre Le
Pelletier dans le Figaro si on en croit
un sondage
Ifop JDD Emmanuel Macron renforce
d'ailleurs sa popularité auprès des
jeunes il gagne 8 points chez les 18 24
ans le président moi ça ça me fait
halluciner devra comme gage mettre un
portrait de McFly et Carlito sur son
bureau lors de son allocution du 14
juillet moi j'hallucine
parce que ça prend toute la France en
otage un petit peu quand même
heureusement que le gage c'était pas
qu'il se promène en tutu kaki sur les
Champs-Élysées parce qu'on y aurait eu
droit alors bon on ne peut pas parler
d'un côté de grandeur du pays de l'autre
d'autorité engueuler un gosse qui vous a
appelé Manu et puis à côté de ça joue
aux amuseurs publics dans une vidéo avec
des youtubeurs il peut aussi aller
pourquoi pas passer quelques jours chez
les nudistes tout nus pour séduire le
camp électoral dénudiste bon tout cela
est et d'une infinitrice
on va être honnête j'ai trouvé que cette
opération elle était très réussie pour
Emmanuel Macron il est presque plus
drôle que en fait il est on le sent très
à l'aise il joue très très bien la
comédie ce qui est plutôt inquiétant
d'ailleurs dans le jardin de l'Elysée
quand le Saint des Saints sur la 5e
République on a un groupe de punk à
chien breton avec une crête qui hurle
une chanson qui s'appelle une souris
verte avec une crête de punk à chien
enfin c'est c'est surréaliste bonsoir à
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je trouve que les deux là ils ont fait
un super boulot et qui sont formidables
dans leur façon de rester eux-mêmes dans
une séquence tellement difficile où on
est écrasé par les dorures le palais et
le président lui-même ça me permet juste
de donner quand même voilà un petit un
petit commentaire sur sur leur
prestations à eux
tout de suite une alerte je suis passé
sur le cas du Jean-Michel avec la radio
clinique radio monsieur Hassan
ça a été très vite le nombre de malades
atteint de la covid 19 continue de
diminuer dans les hôpitaux français
19720 patients sont actuellement
hospitalisés le chiffre pas sous la
barre des 20000 pour la première fois
depuis le 27 octobre dernier même
tendance dans les services de soins
critiques
occupés actuellement par 3515 patients
atteints donc de la covid-19
c'est pas vrai
il n'a pas pu participer à la fête de
l'indépendance en Israël parce que il ne
se fait pas mettre son propre vaccin il
a été un problème
j'ai simplement déploré pendant toute
cette période qu'on vient de traverser
qui nous est pris pour des neuneus qui
nous est infantilisés à ce point-là et
qui nous ont dit au bout du compte
attention parce que vous allez aller au
piquer en plus voilà leur 160 euros et
toutes ces conneries là j'ai vomissage
et j'ai trouvé ça mais vraiment
irresponsable quoi de prendre les gens
pour des cons comme ça des bisous avec
les animaux de la basse-cour c'est le
message très sérieux diffusé par la
principale agence fédérale de santé
publique en cause quelques cas de
salmonellose qui inquiète les autorités
et qui sont en partie liées à des
contacts directs avec des poules ou des
poulets il est donc recommandé de se
laver scrupuleusement les mains après
tout contact rapproché avec une volaille
Nicolas et donc d'arrêter d'embrasser
des poulets même en cette période où
beaucoup veulent afficher leur soutien
aux forces de l'ordre
[Musique]
ah ça va le finir monsieur
c'est la police ouvrez monsieur une
pluie d'insultes qui va durer 10 bonnes
minutes allez où
coupe la musique
[Musique]
j'ai ramené quand même mes amandes oui
que je n'ai pas pu encore régler pour
des raisons mais c'est juste
d'organisation
je décide de fêter les 54 de Monsieur
milowboy Paris quand même la descendance
de Joe boy paris non mais 50 000 abonnés
mon fils sur son compte fan c'est quand
même son compte fan c'est mignon quand
même c'est trop mignon
en 2016 il faut quand même voir à quel
point et à quel stade on en est 2016 un
réseau social à censurer cette image
parce que la statue a des seins nus ce
même réseau social qui laisse proliférer
n'importe quel insulte raciste homophobe
grossophobes que vous voulez vous pouvez
le lire sur ces réseaux mais pas de
seins nus en bronze les limites de
l'intelligence
je sais pas influenceur
peut-être un petit candidat de
téléréalité
mon fils ce sera un peintre il y a rien
qui me dégoûte chez toi je te jure il y
a rien qui me dégoûte même tu c'est
bizarre mais même si tu vas aux
toilettes je m'en fous je pourrais être
à côté de toi non mais c'est vrai tu
vois j'ai aucun dégoût non
c'est vrai mais c'est vrai tu vois prout
c'est prout oui
[Applaudissements]
comme je dis souvent baisse ta culotte
c'est moi qui pileote
moi je voulais faire un stage pilote
d'avion mais il voulait pas ouais après
je vous le dis je veux faire des films X
d'abord il voulait
[Musique]
passer
première fois qu'on tient le manche et
que c'est nous qui les colons et c'est
nous qui atterrissons on se on se fait
un peu dessus mais c'est assez sympa
première fois contient le mange on se
fait un peu de dessus je vous laisse
dégueulasse gérer cette image c'est vrai
que ça les images sont fortes je vous
propose de voir une séquence
pour ouvrir Chambord radio aussi limité
le nombre de visiteurs 1200
et nous ne sommes pas en mesure de
diffuser la fin de ce reportage
excusez-nous pour ce problème technique